le jeune homme épuisé ne réagit pas aux
propos de sa patronne celle-ci commet
alors un geste d'une violence
inexplicable je me retourne et elle
prend un couteau et elle me plante notre
cœur et poumon j'ai sorti une piqûre
une piqûre une piqûre intense mais sans
plus c'est que j'ai regardé j'avais un
couteau planté quoi
ce jour-là
l'esclavagisme était aboli en France
esclave un mot qui semble venir d'un
autre temps et pourtant
l'esclavage existe toujours parfois tout
près de chez nous dans notre ville
à 13 ans Tina a quitté son pays elle
espérait des jours meilleurs
adolescents Christophe aussi rêvait d'un
bel avenir
que sont devenus esclaves
depuis que j'ai découvert leur histoire
je ne cesse de m'interroger comment à
notre époque peut-on encore accepter ça
je m'appelle Christophe Lavigne j'ai 32
ans j'étais victime des Savages modernes
je m'appelle j'ai 24 ans j'étais une
esclave pendant quatre ans et demi
[Musique]
en France l'esclavage existe toujours
cela peut se passer n'importe où Dina et
Christophe en sont la preuve vivante
avant de réussir un jour à enfin briser
leur chaîne ils ont été aussi victimes
de l'esclavage moderne des victimes
condamnées à souffrir en silence
[Musique]
comme tous les jours dans les couloirs
de cette maison de retraite Tina une
jeune femme de 25 ans s'occupe de ses
patients voilà je vais vous installer
pour le goûter
je vous mets comme ça
à tout de suite
pour elle ce travail auprès de personnes
âgées représente un nouveau départ après
une jeunesse marquée par la souffrance
quand j'ai honte de cette vidéo ça me
donne du joie parfois et parfois quand
je me sens pas bien je vais au travail
[Musique]
Tina évolue dans un environnement
épanouissant elle renoue avec un bonheur
qu'il a abandonné depuis l'adolescence
lorsque âgé de 13 ans sa vie a basculé
à l'époque elle vit à Lagos au Nigeria
un pays d'Afrique anglophone un jour une
amie de la famille la femme de Godwin
ockparat une star du football qui évolue
dans le prestigieux club du Paris
Saint-Germain fait une offre parents de
Tina elle leur propose d'adopter la
jeune fille pour lui offrir une vie
meilleure en France la femme de Monsieur
elle a fait la demande d'adoption auprès
de mes parents elle m'a promis que
j'irai à l'école et tout ça je me suis
dit
peut-être c'est une occasion pourquoi
pas la saisie
pour Tina l'avenir s'annonce prometteur
elle devient la fille aînée d'une riche
famille qui compte plusieurs enfants
arrivé en France elle emménage dans la
région parisienne elle doit s'adapter à
une nouvelle vie et à prendre le
français
au début avec la famille orpara ça se
passe bien je m'occupe un peu les
enfants et un peu de tâches ménagères vu
que je suis la fille aînée donc
ça me dérange pas trop et
la seule chose qui me manquait c'est le
fait de ne pas aller à l'école
au départ les oeuc para demande à Tina
d'attendre
vivante avant d'aller à l'école
seulement voilà quelques mois plus tard
elle commence à comprendre que les
choses ne vont pas se passer comme prévu
elle a acheté des livres
et les cartables pour les enfants sauf
que elle a rien acheté pour moi c'est là
que je commence à avoir des soupçons que
il y a quelque chose qui cloche je dis
mon épaule au mien et c'est là qu'elle
m'a fait comprendre que j'irai pas à
l'école je suis bonne à rien et que je
suis pas assez intelligent parler à
l'école que elle a pas l'argent à cacher
dans ce moment là j'ai compris que tous
ces premiers ce qu'elle a fait à mes
parents ce sera pas le cas ça c'est un
cauchemar
du jour au lendemain Tina devient une
esclave la famille déménage pour Chatou
à côté de Paris dans sa nouvelle maison
Tina n'a plus de chambre on l'installe
dans la cave
[Musique]
elle m'a dit que je suis c'est là-bas ma
place donc je dois aller j'avais un
petit matelas qui fait qui fait à peu
près à cette épaisseur que je m'étais
pas terre pour dormir le lendemain quand
je me lève le matin il est mouillé je
tremblais parce que c'est humide ça
sentait pas bon Linda au Para impose un
nouveau mode de vie à Tina
[Musique]
exploite Tina jusqu'à la tombée de la
nuit
si madame est réveillée je dois lui
faire son petit déjeuner
c'est plutôt le déjeuner parce qu'elle
se lève tard et après ça je
lave les vêtements des enfants à la main
pourtant il y a mâché pour elle il faut
pas que j'utilise la machine à laver
donc je lave les affaires de les enfants
à main je lave les assiettes aussi
j'ai fait à peu près à tout à la maison
pour la jeune fille il est impossible
d'échapper à son sort à la moindre
résistance sa mère adoptive la puni
sévèrement
se met en colère c'est franchement ça
c'est pas beau à voir parce que mon
frappé
et quand elle me frappait avec n'importe
quoi et pour me frapper même avec ses
chaussures en talon
âgé de 13 ans seulement Tina comprend
qu'elle est tombée dans un piège loin de
chez elle sans lien avec sa famille
d'origine l'adolescente doit faire face
à une situation qui semble insoluble je
sais que j'étais pas traitée comme les
autres j'ai fait un peu près tout à la
maison
je suis pas aimé
je suis pas bienvenu je me dis je suis
pas bien bienvenue dans la famille
je suis manigné j'ai pas de nouvelles de
ma famille biologique
et ça m'a fait beaucoup mal parce que
voilà je commence à plus à poser à ma
famille
esclave je dirais que oui j'étais très
dépouiller l'esclaves mais il esclave je
pense pas qu'il y aurait un traité comme
ça
pas qu'est-ce que j'ai fait pour mériter
ça malgré la crainte que lui inspire ses
bourreaux un jour Tina décide de réagir
prenons son courage à deux mains elles
s'enfuit elle est alors hébergée par une
bande de jeunes très vite ils appellent
la police qui prend en charge Tina mais
d'après leur fichier elle est recherchée
pour fugue quand ils ont vu que j'étais
à l'enfant de gare du Nord par an
ils sont foutez carrément de moi donc
tout qu'est-ce qui est les intéresse
c'est
au goût du noir le joueur de Paris
Saint-Germain
à l'époque Tina ne parle que l'anglais
et ne parvient pas à convaincre les
policiers inconscient du danger qui
guette la jeune fille ils appellent la
famille ochpara quelques heures plus
tard la grand-mère adoptive de Tina se
présente au commissariat
je vois la mamie devant moi j'ai dit
merde là c'est fini je vais mourir
mais en même temps je me dis que toute
façon
j'ai rien
il me reste à rien
si je vais mourir je vais mourir je peux
pas
Sylvie Audi vous êtes journaliste et
présidente du Comité contre l'esclavage
moderne quelle est la définition de
l'esclavage aujourd'hui au 21e siècle
alors l'esclavage est en fait la
privation de liberté
la contrainte par un travail absolument
exorbitant de droit commun 14h 16h par
jour la configuration des passeports
l'isolement familial et culturel j'en ai
plus de contact avec l'extérieur et
évidemment il y a malheureusement des
mauvais traitements en fait à la fois
physique et psychologique en fait il y a
une espèce d'emprise la personne qui
esclavagiste quelqu'un à une emprise
psychologique sur cette personne qui
remplace
au fond les chaînes d'autrefois on a
l'impression justement que c'est quelque
chose d'un autre temps est-ce que c'est
répandu aujourd'hui en France on reçoit
à peu près 300 signalements par an mais
donc finalement ne sont pas tous
forcément de l'esclavage mais il y en a
quand même bien chaque année peut-être
une bonne centaine qui relève vraiment
de la traite des êtres humains ou de
l'esclavage et qui sont-ils alors les
esclaves se sont en grande majorité des
femmes sinon parfois on a un couple
l'homme et la femme sont employés en
tant que domestique par par des gens
très riches ce sont en majorité des
personnes d'origine étrangère qui ont
été amenées en France pour être
esclavagé soit de l'hôtel particulier du
16e arrondissement au HLM de mon lieu ou
dans une exploitation agricole dans la
campagne ce sont des gens extrêmement
vulnérables ce qui les définit le mieux
c'est leur vulnérabilité quand ils
arrivent ici souvent ils ne parlent pas
la langue ils n'ont pas du tout de lien
familiaux ils n'ont pas ils ne vont pas
voir leur église donc ils sont
totalement à la merci de la personne qui
les conduit ici et qui leur dit au fond
surtout un pouvoir de vie et de mort
contrairement à ces craintes tinout para
ne sera pas puni pour avoir essayé de
s'évader pourtant quelques mois plus
tard ses parents adoptifs franchiront un
degré supplémentaire dans la cruauté
[Musique]
en 1995 Christophe Lavigne à 16 ans
cette année-là il obtient un contrat
d'apprentissage dans une boulangerie
d'Arcachon pour lui c'est une aubaine
après trois ans de travail en alternance
il va enfin pouvoir réaliser son rêve
devenir boulanger les premières années
tout se passait bien la deuxième année
aussi c'est à partir de la troisième
année où ça a commencé un peu à monter à
monter de ton
[Musique]
mais en violation de la loi aucun
contrat n'est signé Christophe découvre
alors que sa nouvelle vie de boulanger
ne va pas ressembler à ce qu'il
imaginait ma journée a commencé à partir
de 3 heures du matin au réveil enfant
phare parce que mon patron il venait me
réveiller à coup de se doudou dans la
gueule ensuite c'était bon mais on
faisait le boulot comme d'habitude mais
on finissait à 13h après on allait
manger avec eux je mangeais avec eux
dans leur cuisine une fois que tout
était fini on allait se coucher on
dormait deux heures on reprenait après
l'après-midi si c'était l'hiver on
prenait pas on allait chez eux faire une
fois du jardinage soit de la plomberie
soit faire des charpentes et ce n'est
pas tout les boulangers profitent de la
jeunesse de pouvoir employé pour
l'exploiter financièrement pour mon
salaire en fait ça se passait comme ça
c'est que mon patron avait décidé
d'ouvrir un compte pour moi pour verser
l'argent de mon salaire dans ce compte
c'est la fin du mois j'avais juste une
enveloppe de 150 euros
[Musique]
ils ont commencé à me menacer de me dire
que ils allaient vendre la boulangerie
et que il me vendrait avec en fait je
comprenais pas ce qu'il disait
l'apprenti boulanger est considéré comme
un bulle se multiplie
ils ont commencé à me brimer en me
disant que je ferai rien de ma vie plus
tard avec je resterai toujours avec eux
parce que je trouverai personne d'autre
au bout d'un moment mais tu commences à
croire ce qu'ils disent et tu te sens
enferme à l'intérieur de toi-même et
puis tu parles plus quoi tu te laisses
tu te laisses aller tu fais ce qu'ils
disent et puis voilà quoi un peu comme
un pantin quoi
Christophe Lavigne est constamment
rabaissé et humilié ces patrons exercent
sur lui une véritable emprise
[Musique]
je peux pas sortir je voyais je voyais
le couloir avec la porte qui me tendait
les bras pour partir mais j'osais même
pas partir je sais même pas franchir le
pas plusieurs mois après être soi-disant
passé en CDI la
situation
[Musique]
tous les matins je lui ai demandé que
j'avais besoin de se défouler sur moi
parce que j'étais tout seul et que ça
lui fait je fais pas ça faisait du bien
de se défouler sur quelqu'un depuis
faible que lui donc
il me prenait pour son petit bol la vie
de Christophe
[Musique]
de vie pas à employer la menace
à part sortir leur chien et chercher des
cigarettes et de l'alcool je faisais et
sortir les poubelles c'est tout ce que
je faisais quand il m'autorisait de
sortir le soir je pouvais sortir mais
certaines conditions c'est que il
fallait que je rentre
à une certaine heure sinon la porte
était fermée et je dormais dehors à
l'époque pour Christophe le seul espoir
de s'échapper ce sont ses parents durant
les vacances d'été il doit normalement
rentrer dans sa famille mais ses patrons
inventent un mensonge pour le retenir
chez eux et ça marche les parents de
Christophe leur accordent plus de
crédits à leur propre fils j'ai pas eu
de vacances pendant trois années de ça
car mes patrons disaient à mes parents
que je restais sur le Bassin d'Arcachon
comme il faisait beau et que j'avais
envie de profiter de la plage alors que
c'était pas du tout ça et que je
travaillais comme les jours normaux
donc non j'avais pas de vacances
pendant ce temps là
sylview dit le cas de Christophe est
assez emblématique on se rend compte que
l'esclavage peut prendre des formes très
variées oui c'est effectivement très
frappant de voir ce grand garçon parce
que c'est quand même un grand garçon qui
se retrouve totalement
sous emprise de ses patrons mais nous on
le comprend très bien parce que d'abord
il est arrivé très jeune je crois qu'il
avait 15 ans quand ça a commencé il
était sans aucun sans doute sans
beaucoup de défense personnelle
peut-être pas soutenu par sa famille
comme vous l'expliquez dans le reportage
et à ce moment-là il y a eu ce qu'on
appelle nous on appelle l'emprise
psychologique c'est quelque chose de
très précis qui fait que quelqu'un ne
peut plus se défendre que même si la
porte est là à
5 mètres de lui la personne a tellement
terrorisé il a tellement peur qu'il ne
partira pas et qu'il faut qu'il y ait un
jour quelque chose de plus violent
quelque chose de plus fort quelque chose
de plus dur pour qu'il ait le courage de
s'enfuir
[Musique]
sans amis ne pouvant pas compter sur
l'aide de sa famille Christophe est
livré à lui-même il va donc essayer de
trouver le moyen de s'en sortir tout
seul
[Musique]
en France depuis un an et demi Tina
maintenant âgé de 14 ans est toujours
exploitée par le footballeur Godwin o
para et sa femme Linda peu à peu la
situation empire au début c'est pas là
pourquoi
je vous dis mission pareil les lieux que
sa femme je prenais bien au père je
l'appelais père
et malgré tout ça [__] pas violer
pendant 3 ans
abuse de sa fille adoptive en 2005 sa
femme Linda le surprend alors qu'il est
en train de Violetta après une violente
dispute le footballeur quitte le
domicile conjugal Linda au Para décide
alors de se venger sur son esclave hélas
c'est un jus que je lui ai jamais oublié
dans ma vie
de la salle de bain elle a pris ton dos
jusqu'à quand ça va après un détour à la
cuisine madame Okpara revient avec une
lame de rasoir une bouteille de vodka et
de la purée de piment elle est là en
train de m'insulter il y avait la mamie
à ses à côté
la bouteille enfoncez ça dans le vagin
je supplie
ait à leçon prochainement tu coucheras
pas avec alors forcé
et là madame
[Musique]
de ta vie à chaque fois que tu vas te
regarder dans le miroir
elle a raison
après cette séance de torture Linda ou
para pousse le sadisme à obliger Tina à
nettoyer la chambre des enfants m'acculé
de son propre sang
l'amour que je pourrais avoir auprès de
ma famille et ma voler tout ça mon rêve
désormais Tina et déterminé à ne plus
subir le 13 août 2005 alors que Godwin
s'apprête à nouveau à la violer la jeune
fille profite d'un moment d'inattention
pour s'enfuir elle sera recueillie par
des personnes du quartier après avoir
écouté son récit il prévienne la police
et m'ont amené dans le commissariat
et là j'étais heureux j'étais
je me dis que ça y est mon cauchemar
c'est fini
que je vais construire la vie
je voyais plus la famille
aujourd'hui pour la toute première fois
depuis son évasion Tina revient sur les
lieux de son calvaire c'est ici par ce
jardin mitoyen de celui de la maison des
hautes-para qu'elle a retrouvé le chemin
de la liberté il y a 7 ans une fois
traversé
la porte l'arrière je vous dis saute je
saute je vais où après je saute encore
je continue à sauter sauter sauter
jusqu'à quand je veux me trouver ici là
je me dis cours cours Tina tu cours pas
assez mais je continue à courir juste
pour
le fait de courir c'est aller loin de ne
plus les voir en même temps quand je
cours je regarde l'arrière derrière moi
pour savoir si ils sont derrière moi on
va tuer ou quoi ce soir mais la seule
chose que je pense sur le coup c'est
courir aller loin pour Tina
reparler de ses événements tragiques et
difficiles mais c'est aussi essentiel
pour prouver à tout ce que l'esclavage
existe encore
Annick vous êtes avocate et vous avez
fondé l'association SOS Esclaves
c'est compliqué de prouver de faire
reconnaître son statut d'esclave
c'est très compliqué parce que le statut
d'esclave n'existe pas
l'esclavage n'existe pas dans la loi
puisque il a été aboli
et donc il faut arriver pour pouvoir
faire reconnaître le statut d'esclavage
à rentrer dans des textes qui ne sont
pas fait pour ça il faut rentrer dans
les définitions du code pénal qui
concerne la traite des êtres humains
parce que on est dans ce sujet là
simplement il faut donner à la justice
et d'abord à la police des éléments
suffisants pour permettre de faire
aboutir une procédure et donc ça c'est
pas facile du tout parce que on n'a pas
les outils pour pour arriver à ça alors
quels sont les armes justement
aujourd'hui en France pour pouvoir
lutter contre l'esclavage bah les armes
c'est d'épatouiller se débrouiller avec
l'arsenal répressif existant pour
obtenir des condamnations et on en
obtient mais c'est très compliqué et il
faudrait que le législateur veuille bien
se pencher sur ce problème qui n'est pas
un problème anecdotique du tout qui
existe qui est dans notre pays qui est
dans la rue d'à côté et donc qu'il
faudrait savoir réprimer de manière
normale
libre mais pour elle un autre combat
commence faire condamner ses bourreaux
mais aussi retrouver son nom de famille
biologique et abandonné celui de ses
parents adoptifs
[Musique]
cela fait maintenant trois ans que
Christophe Lavigne est esclave mais un
jour de 1998 sa situation va s'aggraver
ce matin-là le jeune homme entame sa
journée de travail à 13h il rejoint ses
patrons pour déjeuner
j'ai fini de travailler je commence à
arriver à la cuisine ils avaient tout
débarrassé tout ça donc bon j'ai fait
comme d'habitude je me mets au lavabo je
me lave les mains et tout ça et à
patronne commence à me dire mais tu vas
te casser au lit tu vas pas manger tu as
vu l'heure qu'il est ça sert à rien je
vais pas faire un repas pour toi de
toute manière tu mangeras mieux ce soir
tu vas au lit donc j'ai pas j'ai pas
trop bien saisi parce que j'étais un peu
fatigué en même temps
inexplicable je me retourne et elle
prend un couteau et elle me plante notre
cœur et poumon j'ai sorti une piqûre
une piqûre une piqûre intense mais sans
plus c'est que j'ai regardé j'avais un
couteau planté quoi et c'est quand elle
a ressorti que je suis tombé par terre
quoi
[Musique]
je suis resté cinq jours avec la
blessure
pour souffler avoir mal comme pas
possible à travailler pendant 5 jours
jusqu'à ce que ça commence à gonfler à
gonfler à gonfler j'en pleurais j'avais
trop mal le pus du couler c'était
horrible mais bon il me soignait de
temps en temps mais fallait que j'aille
voir chirurgien mais c'était pas
je savais très bien que là j'étais à
deux doigts de mourir je le sentais à
moi-même
petit à petit Christophe
fatoum par guérir de ses blessures
mais alors qu'il est en convalescence
à
la Grèce c'est la foi de trop
il me faut un coup de poing dans la
figure et je tombe par terre et il me
dit tu refais ça je te défonce
et à ce moment là mais là j'ai commencé
à
réagir je pense que ces phrases va faire
réagir et j'ai tout laissé en plan j'ai
tout laissé ce que j'avais fait au four
dans le pétrin tout ça je suis parti en
courant
et il m'a dit je me rappelle toujours il
m'a dit vas-y casse-toi je te
retrouverai je te ferai la peau et à ce
moment là mais je suis parti j'ai couru
le plus vite possible au commissariat
ils ont été affolé les policiers quand
ils m'ont vu je tremblais de partout je
vais je dis j'ai juste j'ai envie de
porter plainte j'ai envie de porter
plainte j'ai envie de porter plainte
j'ai envie juste de ça quoi
bon tenter en désespoir de cause de
discréditer leur esclave ils ont appelé
mes parents en leur disant que fallait
pas qu'il s'inquiète que j'allais
peut-être leur téléphoner comme quoi il
m'avait donné un coup de couteau mais
c'est pas vrai en fait c'est m'étais
ouvert avec un nouveau boite mes parents
ils ont cru mais pas trop mais pas moi
dans ma tête je me suis dit waouh je
l'ai fait je suis parti quoi j'ai réussi
à partir
enseignement déclencheur il y a toujours
un événement qui fait que quelque chose
va faire vaciller vaciller l'emprise ça
peut être une intervention extérieure ça
peut être quelque chose ou l'agresseur
va trop loin Christophe dit que c'est
une phrase qui l'a fait qui a fait
vaciller quelque chose il peut pas dire
pourquoi cette phrase c'est comme un
message codé au fond dans son histoire
c'est comme un rêve faudrait la décoder
comme un rêve parce que le coup de
couteau ne le fait pas partir mais cette
phrase le mais cette phrase le fait
partie mais ça veut dire que cette
phrase est venue frapper des choses chez
lui qui lui ont rendu son être d'une
certaine façon c'est comme si tout d'un
coup il s'était réveillé je peux sortir
et le cercle magique de l'emprise
perverse s'est brisée
Christophe Lavigne a enfin réussi à
surmonter sa peur il est désormais un
homme libre un nouveau chapitre de sa
vie va commencer il doit maintenant
s'adapter à une société dont il ignore
les codes
[Musique]
après avoir retrouvé une vie à peu près
normale Tina va mener une longue
bataille juridique pour faire condamner
ses bureaux en 2008 au terme de deux
procès la cour d'assises des
Hauts-de-Seine condamne respectivement
Godwin et Linda au Para à 10 et 15 ans
de réclusion criminelle pour viol
torture et asservissement de leur fille
adoptive
durant cette épreuve Tina aura pu
compter sur l'aide de bienveillante de
son avocate Martine perron mais
aujourd'hui elle doit lui annoncer une
mauvaise nouvelle Godwin octarat devrait
sortir de prison prochainement je sais
qui c'est il pouvait potentiellement
sortir à partir du mois de décembre
je sais qu'il est moi méchant c'est à
dire il est pas exactement comme sa
femme mais je sais pas pourtant malgré
ses craintes Tina ne risque rien
Léopards ont été condamnés à une
interdiction définitive du territoire
français aujourd'hui l'ancienne esclave
doit plutôt se concentrer sur un autre
combat récupérer le nom de ses parents
biologiques
mission pareil il est pas digne
d'un père et
et je supporte pas quand les gens
m'appelaient mademoiselle ou à Madame
parce que c'est
ça me rappelle pas si donc au jus
d'aujourd'hui j'ai essayé de
reconstruire ma vie et j'aimerais bien
changer le fait que je portais le nom
monsieur
malheureusement Tina est confronté à un
problème juridique de taille sa
nationalité pour l'instant Tina est
toujours de nationalité nigériane donc
la France ne peut pas prendre une
décision sur sur un individu sur un
citoyen qui n'est pas de sa nationalité
bien évidemment donc il faudrait d'abord
que Tina obtienne la nationalité
française et pour l'instant elle est
loin d'obtenir la nationalité française
puisqu'elle essaye d'avoir un titre de
séjour durable ce qui n'est pas son cas
pour la jeune femme qui a vécu plus
longtemps ce que dans son pays
[Musique]
d'ouvrir la nationalité française est
vécue comme une injustice
je sais que ils disent que pour être une
bonne français ou une bonne française il
faut déjà maîtriser la langue avoir un
travail stable avoir un logement j'ai
tout ce qu'il faut mais je vois pas
pourquoi et le raison que j'ai pas le
papier français
aujourd'hui Tina doit retourner
régulièrement en préfecture faire des
démarches administratives pour elle être
expulsée au Nigeria son pays d'origine
serait un drame car sa patrie maintenant
c'est la France
[Musique]
après son évasion Christophe Lavigne
grièvement blessé reste hospitalisée
pendant trois mois
à sa sortie de l'hôpital en 2001 sans
nouvelles de sa famille il est pris en
charge par des éducateurs qui le place
dans un foyer
le foyer c'est une bonne chose mais
c'est assez bizarre pour moi il y avait
trop de différence il y avait trop de
changements d'un coup c'était trop
rapide et pour moi je me sentais encore
enfermé même si on sortait de temps en
temps j'étais paumé j'étais complètement
paumé
de s'adapter à sa nouvelle vie au foyer
il est en lutte permanente contre toute
forme d'autorité
son éducateur se voit dans l'obligation
de le renvoyer seul et sans ressource
c'est ici sur un banc aujourd'hui
détruit que le jeune homme trouve refuge
je suis allé sur ce banc parce que mon
éducateur
pensait que j'étais pas apte à rester au
foyer parce que j'étais pas du tout
social avec les gens j'étais gris
j'étais méchant j'étais je les ai envoyé
bouler tout le temps et il y avait pas
besoin de ça au foyer livré à lui-même
Christophe de positiver il réalise en
effet que malgré cette situation
précaire il ne sera plus jamais
l'esclave de personnes
sortir et que j'allais j'allais remonter
la pente et relever la tête et
donc j'étais certain de pas rester là
depuis trop longtemps
[Musique]
expérience Christophe trouve un emploi
dans une boulangerie
[Musique]
le premier salaire que j'ai eu quand
j'ai retravaillé j'ai halluciné parce
que j'ai vu 3-0 et
alors c'était juste un salaire normal
avec de quelqu'un qui travaille et quoi
[Musique]
Christophe travaille dans cette nouvelle
boulangerie d'Arcachon ce matin son
nouveau patron monsieur Lavenne contrôle
l'avancée de la fabrication
[Musique]
le patron n'a pas de souci à se faire
de 15 ans Christophe connaît son métier
sur le bout des doigts
moi j'ai pas besoin d'être derrière lui
je m'occupe du poste pâtisserie et lui
tout ce qui est poste boulangerie c'est
lui qui s'en occupe qui gère
car malgré ces traumatismes son métier
de boulanger est resté une passion le
fait de continuer ce métier là ça a été
une sorte de revanche par rapport à mes
anciens patrons qui croyait que j'allais
peut-être arrêter par rapport à ce
qu'ils ont ce qu'ils m'ont fait et que
qu'ils auraient gagné finalement non ils
ont pas gagné parce que je continue et
j'aime bien ce que j'adore ce métier et
voilà c'est une façon pour moi de
me dire que
qu'ils ont perdu quoi
Christophe a retrouvé un équilibre
professionnel mais il garde au fond de
lui un blocage psychologique dans mon
métier je me vois pas patron vu ce que
j'ai vécu c'est pas possible je ne
pourrai pas je pourrais pas vivre ça
mais par contre oui rester un temps que
vous voyez et
faire mon métier de boulanger travailler
comme il faut et puis peut-être de
monter en grade et puis après peut-être
s'installer avec quelqu'un et puis avoir
des enfants et une famille quoi une
vraie famille
[Musique]
en 2001 Christophe Lavigne a déposé une
plainte contre ses anciens bourreaux
[Musique]
si je devais décrire ce que j'ai vécu ça
serait juste l'enfer le bagne la prison
j'avais pas dit sentimentale j'avais pas
de vie personnelle je voyais personne je
travaillais c'est dur sur 7 24 heures
sur 24 aujourd'hui
il retrouve rafaillac l'avocat qui l'a
représenté lors des procès qui l'ont
opposé à ses anciens patrons
le temps passe vite
bon patrons super gentil
nous n'avions pas à faire à une pauvre
petite étrangère qui était exploitée
dans un appartement du 16e
arrondissement on avait affaire à notre
enfant on avait affaire un apprenti on
avait affaire un jeune français ça
pourrait être évidemment quelqu'un de
notre entourage il a le fait que je
crois que ça a marqué véritablement les
esprits c'est à dire que l'abomination a
les paliers entièrement
l'abomination elle est à notre porte et
je crois que le diable il se fige sans
doute dans le détail mais là en il peut
être votre voisin celui qui vous sourit
au quotidien et qui est un monstre et
c'est un peu l'idée que l'on avait
lorsque l'on se promenait à Arcachon
dans cette jolie voix piétonnière et que
l'on se retrouvait devant cette
magnifique boulangerie pâtisserie avec
ces gens qui étaient des gens établis
qui étaient connus qui était apprécié
même d'ailleurs par les institutions
locales et pourtant et pourtant c'était
c'était de véritablement
les boulangers ont été condamnés à un an
de prison dont 6 mois avec sursis et à
l'interdiction d'exercer leur profession
une peine qui laisse un goût amer à
Christophe
j'attendais qu'il aille se fait qu'il se
fasse on va dire
une bonne peine de prison mais j'étais
assez déçu je pensais que j'allais faire
plus quand même par rapport à ce qu'ils
ont fait c'est pas
c'est pas logique
l'esclavagisme n'est pas inscrit dans le
code pénal est-ce que il sera un jour
est-ce que c'est prévu dans mes
aujourd'hui effectivement comme il a été
aboli on ne peut pas inculper qui compte
d'esclavagisme aujourd'hui donc on
utilise d'autres
articles du Code pénal alors il y a
depuis 2007 un article contre la traite
des êtres humains qui est effectivement
très importante parce qu'il permet quand
une victime porte plainte contre la
personne qui l'a traité ainsi qu'elle
puisse obtenir des papiers le temps des
procès donc on a cette partie là et on a
un arc des articles évidemment tout ce
qui est séquestration coups et blessures
agression sexuelle et conditions
d'hébergement contraire la dignité
humaine et conditions de travail et
quand ils travaillent au contraire donc
on a un arsenal mais évidemment ça n'est
pas le mot d'esclavagisme n'existe pas
dans le code pénal
[Musique]
obligé de conserver le nom de famille de
ses bourreaux au moins provisoirement
Tina octarat tente d'oublier cette
frustration aux côtés de ses meilleurs
amis Natacha et Marie Chantal qu'elle
surnomme tatie
la jeune fille les a rencontrés à
l'époque où elle prenait des cours de
français dans un foyer
[Musique]
tu te souviens la première fois tu n'as
que que qu'on s'est connu
je rappelle ou pas
gentil douce je suis toujours gentille
d'abord simple amis les trois jeunes
femmes sont devenues inséparables
aujourd'hui la nouvelle famille de Tina
c'est Marie Chantal et Natacha dès que
j'ai su son histoire j'ai adopté
j'ai je me suis mis à la place d'une
maman j'ai des enfants de son âge et je
me dis mais attends je rêve j'ai réalisé
pas chercher vraiment une amour
d'une mère et puis bon je pouvais pas
remplacer sa maman bien évidemment mais
je donnais
le peu que que je peux donner du coup on
est devenu complice on est quoi on est
tante et nièce copine complice on fait
des 400 coups ensemble
le soutien de cette famille de coeur est
vital pour Tina car malgré sa grande
force de caractère elle ne peut pas se
reconstruire toute seule avoir une
famille c'est très important parce que
déjà l'amour que j'ai pas eu auprès de
mes parents parce que je les appelle du
jeûne et l'amour que j'ai
pas eu auprès de la famille au hasard
Afrique au jus d'aujourd'hui je le
trouve auprès de Natacha et taxi
donc cet amour m'aider à avancer ce sont
des
je dirais ce sont des moteurs ce sont
les gens qui qui me donnent la pêche ou
au papa même quand ça passe mal de
travail je les appelle
je sais pas je pense que la famille
c'est tout c'est la famille on peut pas
avancer dans la vie une famille
Tina espère aussi un jour en fonder une
se marier et avoir des enfants
[Musique]
Christophe Lavigne aussi a dû se recréer
une famille
ses parents ne l'ont jamais défendu il a
décidé de les rayer de sa vie
sachant que j'ai plus de famille mes
amis j'ai considéré un peu comme ma
famille et c'est eux qui ont réussi à me
remettre à Rémy faire la fête à Roy
aimer les gens à rigoler un sourire à
faire plein de choses ce soir Christophe
a rendez-vous avec Priscilla et Grégoire
ces deux plus vieux amis
ça va bien
et toi
ils ont connu Christophe au moment où il
recommençait à travailler à cette époque
le jeune homme était inadapté à la vie
en société quand on a rencontré
Christophe en fait il était vraiment
dans son monde il était il était pas au
courant de des choses qui se passaient
autour de lui donc on a essayé quand
même de lui montrer des choses et lui
faire comprendre qu'il y avait des
choses qu'il fallait qu'il fasse et pas
d'autres grâce à ses amis
tout ce qui était paperasse niveau
administratif administratif parce que je
connaissais pas grand chose
et tu m'as beaucoup aidé par rapport à
ça Greg m'a beaucoup aussi on va dire
conseiller il m'a donné beaucoup de
conseils
et c'est vrai que ça fait c'est
important quoi qu'on a personne derrière
soi et que on a que des amis enfin que
deux amis à qui on peut faire confiance
c'est vrai que c'est vachement important
vous êtes bien comme ça non
asservi par ses parents adoptifs Tina
n'a jamais pu aller à l'école mais grâce
à des années de travail acharné elle est
parvenue à devenir auxiliaire de vie
dans une maison de retraite ce choix de
métier en fait c'est très important pour
moi parce que
l'amour
que j'ai dans mon métier et je pense pas
que je l'aurais ailleurs bon je peux
partir maintenant
ça c'est
à tout à l'heure
avec son équipe la jeune femme s'occupe
d'une trentaine de patients c'est une
lourde tâche mais Tina s'en a quitte
consciencieusement
la solitude d'une personne âgée dans sa
chambre ou qui quelqu'un qui peut-être à
un moment va pas être bien nous on va
peut-être passer sans faire attention
elle elle va avoir le souci de lui
remonter le moral ou de d'apporter une
présence pour Tina exercer ce métier
alors qu'elle n'a pas fait d'études est
une grande fierté mais désormais elle
veut aller plus loin et devenir
infirmière
au fil des années ce qui furent
autrefois des esclaves ont su brisé leur
chaîne pour reprendre leur destin en
main
ils ont compris que la liberté n'est pas
un droit mais un combat
même s'il reste marqué dans leur corps
et dans leur cœur
laissez ça derrière moi ce n'est pas
possible non parce que j'ai la cicatrice
et la vie c'est je la vois tout le temps
quand je vais me doucher donc quand je
pars à la plage quand tout ça mais après
c'est ma vie je veux dire je vais vivre
avec c'est pas j'arrive j'ai fait le
deuil je fais le deuil de cette histoire
mais voilà c'est ma vie avec c'est comme
ça je sais que mon passé est lourd mais
c'est pas pour autant que je vais
m'engrais je continue à battre
j'espère que je vais y arriver